Hello friends, welcome to your program
3ABN today Bible Q&A. My name is Eidalia
Denzy and I will be sharing this hour
with you at home and those radio
listeners, thank you for tuning in to
3ABN radio. We are excited to spend this
hour with you. I want to share Psalm uh
verse 1 and two. Oh, sing to the Lord a
new song. Sing to the Lord, all the
earth. Sing to the Lord. Bless his name.
Proclaim the good news of his salvation
from day to day. Thank you so much for
being part of this ministry and for
being part of this your program, Bible
Q&A, because it is your questions and
your concerns that we address during the
program. So, thank you. Shortly I will
be sharing the contact information where
you can send your questions. But for now
I'd like to present to you our
panelists, your 3ABN family. We have
Pastor James Raertdy with us. Welcome.
>> Good to be here Dalia. Looking forward
to our program today and answering some
great questions.
>> Yes. Amen. And we have Shellyley Quinn
with us. My my friend, my sister. How
are you?
>> I am wonderful. and I I'm glad you're
here today. We're so glad that you sent
in your questions and we're excited to
share these answers.
>> Amen. You know, Shelly, I love these
programs and Pastor Rafferty, I actually
enjoy them.
>> Yeah.
>> And there's no reason for Bible study to
be boring.
>> That's right.
>> Amen, Pastor Rafferty.
>> Amen.
>> All right. Well, we are going to the
Lord in prayer because uh I know you
have some concerns and we would like
Shelley, if you don't mind, to pray for
our viewers at home because we want the
Holy Spirit to speak to our hearts, to
speak to our ears, and for us to be
sensitive to his voice.
>> Amen. Amen. Our loving heavenly father,
we come before you with praise in our
hearts. As Adalia said,
>> we praise you for your plan of salvation
by grace and righteousness by faith. We
praise you Lord for uh our Lord and
Savior Jesus Christ. We praise you for
the Holy Spirit
>> who empowers us to walk in your your
way, Lord, your true way. And we thank
you for your word as we open this word.
Lord, I ask in the name of Jesus.
>> Give us Lord wisdom from on high. Just
we pray that your Holy Spirit will lead
us into truths. maybe we haven't seen
before. And I ask, Father, that you
would bless our viewers.
>> Amen.
>> Bless those who are listening by radio.
Help us all, Lord, to have ears to hear
what the Holy Spirit would say to us and
a heart
>> that loves you and is eager to obey.
Amen. In Christ, we pray. Amen.
>> Amen. Amen. And amen. Well, yes, your
program. I know you're anticipating the
questions that are going to be
presenting today. But before we go to
the first question, I'd like to share
the email. So that question that just
popped in your mind, you can just send
it in. The email is bible
3abn.tv.
Bible
the text. You can send your text to
6182283975.
That's 6182283975.
And you Instagrammers, yes, you get our
platform too at 3ABN
official.
3ABN
official. So, our first question is from
Ry, and we want to thank Ry for sending
it in. It says like this, Genesis 1:14,
the Amplified states, "Then God said,
let there be lightbearers,
sun, moon, stars in the expanse of the
heavens to separate the day from the
night, and let them be useful for signs
or tokens of God's provident care and
for marking seasons, days, and years. So
it is proven that God's calendar is
based on a lunar solar calendar and the
Sabbath is set each month by the new
moon. When incorporated into the
Gregorian calendar, the Sabbath day will
change each month. Can you elaborate on
this and explain how the true 7th day
Sabbath is correct using Saturday on the
pagan calendar? Pastor Rafferty,
>> that's a great question, Rey. One that
troubled me for quite a while as I was
uh studying with people who were really
into the lunar cycle and the calendar
based on that uh especially with the
Sabbath. So, you'll notice in the text
here, God said, "Let there be lights in
the firmament of the heaven to divide
the day and the night, and let them be
for signs and for seasons and for days
and for years." uh going on there in
Genesis 1 uh 15, let them be for lights
in the firmament and of the heaven to
give light upon the earth. And it was
so. And God made the two great lights,
the greater light to rule the day, the
lesser light to rule the night. He made
the stars also. And God set them in the
firmament of the heaven to give light
upon the earth and to rule over the day
and over the night, and to divide the
light from the darkness. And God saw
that it was good. And the evening and
the morning were the fourth day. So,
there are two points that jump out at us
here. This is day four of a 7-day
creation week. Think about that. God is
setting up seasons and days and years
and months inside a 7-day creation week.
The 7-day creation week is separate from
everything that God is establishing
right here. Now number two is it says in
the text that these lights were for
signs and for seasons for days and for
years to rule the day and to rule the
night. But what does the text leave out?
The text does not mention the week. You
will notice with a careful reading of
these texts again that the weekly cycle
is not mentioned. It says for signs, for
seasons, for days, for years. That days
is not a week. It's 24 hours to rule the
day and to rule the night. So the 7-day
weekly cycle is not based on the lunar
solar calendar. It is simply seven
consecutive days of evening and morning.
There is no variation like we see in the
new moon Sabbath of the ceremonial law.
Each day begins and ends alike with
evening and then morning. Now the
Gregorian calendar does not interfere
with the 7-day weekly cycle in the least
bit. The 7-day weekly cycle was
established by God in the creation week.
And there's been nations that have tried
to change it to a 10-day cycle, but it
has never changed. Changing it to a
10day cycle has never worked in my
opinion because mankind and even God's
creation are rooted by our creator in
the 7day cycle. So, at first I I I was
remember I studied all this literature
about the lunar cycle and the lunar
sabbaths and how do we know which one's
which and and then I realized, wait a
minute, the 7-day weekly cycle, it has
nothing to do with the lunar cycle. Has
nothing. It's outside of all of that. It
is seven consecutive days beginning with
the evening going to the morning that
repeats and repeats and repeats without
change, without interference. Doesn't
matter what the dates are. Doesn't
matter what years are. That 7-day weekly
cycle just continues on. And that is
what the seventh day Sabbath, the fourth
commandment of the Bible that God told
us to remember, that is what that
seventh day Sabbath is based upon, that
weekly cycle, not a lunar cycle. So I
hope Ray that this will help uh to
answer your question.
>> Amen. You know, and then I think Ry,
what you is you're confusing is the
festival Sabbaths. The uh um they had
pardon
>> new moon Sabbaths.
>> New moon Sabbaths. There were annual
festival Sabbaths and then there were
new moon Sabbaths, but that didn't have
anything to do with the seventh day.
>> Thank you, Shelly, and thank you, Pastor
Rafferty. Let's go to the next question
and this is for you Shelley chat sent
in. It says, "What are the triune gods
and what is the significance of being
introduced in the Adventist church?"
Chad, thank you for this question.
There's uh there seems to be a lot of
confusion
um just in the field regarding this.
First of all, I just want to say
Adventists are firmly monotheistic. We
believe in one God, not three gods.
Deuteronomy 6 and verse4 says here, "O
Israel, the Lord our God, the Lord is
one." So what we as Adventists teach is
what the scripture reveals. It's that
this one God has made himself known as
and he exists in three persons. The
Godhead, the Father, Son, and Holy
Spirit. We find that term Godhead in
Acts 17:29,
Romans 1:20, and Colossians 2:9.
That word triune God has because there
are three persons of the same essence,
the same character, but three distinct
persons.
Theologians came up with the word
trinity. Now, that's a theological word
used to summarize the teaching and it is
basically interchangeable with the word
godhead. I I want to say this because I
prefer to use Godhead. That's the Bible.
Trinity is not in the Bible. But neither
is terms like incarnation, omniscient,
omnipotent, substitutionary atonement,
theophony, chrisphony, esquetology.
There's many words that we find
generally acceptable in our church that
are theological terms that as long as
they are clarifying doctrine without
adding to
the teaching then the term doesn't have
to be fine found in the Bible but the
doctrine does. So that's important. And
I just want this is so interesting
because many people get upset over this
word trinity.
>> Even the word Bible's not in the Bible.
It's not in scripture,
>> but it accurately describes collected
scriptures. So the triune God is not
it hasn't just been introduced into our
church as a new revelation. And it was
developed over time as Adventists
studied scripture more deeply. Early
Adventist pioneers came out of many
different Protestant denominations in
the 1800s and there was not immediate
clarity on every theological point. But
through careful Bible study and
especially with passages such as you
might want to jot these down. Matthew
28:19
baptizing in the name that's a singular
name of the father, son, and the holy
spirit. Or John 1:1, the word in the
beginning was the word. The word was
with God and the word was God. John 14
chapters 14-16
Jesus describes the Holy Spirit as our
personal helper. And in 2 Corinthians
13:14
we see the father, son, and the spirit
united in a blessing. So basically the
church came to affirm what scripture
presents. There's one eternal God
revealed in three co-eternal persons who
are perfectly united in character,
purpose, and love. Now, here's the
significance of this teaching. This is
not philosophical.
It is salvational.
If Christ were not fully God, his
atonement would be insufficient.
If the Holy Spirit were not a divine
person as Christ described him, then he
could not convict our hearts, guide us,
talk with us, and sanctify us. If the
father was different in character from
Jesus, we would misunderstand God's
heart. The Godhead reve reveals perfect
unity, perfect love and perfect
cooperation in redemption.
At in Matthew 3 16 and 17 at Jesus
baptism, we see the son is baptized, the
spirit is descending and the father is
speaking from heaven. This is not three
gods. It is one God, three divine
persons and um one divine plan of
salvation. So the question is not about
triune gods plural. There is only one
God.
>> The question is how did that one true
God reveal himself? Scripture shows us
that father, son. It isn't I don't like
people I don't like it when people say
God the Father, God the Son, God the
Holy Spirit. It makes it sound like
there's three gods.
>> It's God the Father, Son, and Holy
Spirit
working in unity to save us. This is not
a new doctrine. It is the unfolding
testimony of Godhead in the scripture.
>> Thank you very much, Shelley. And I want
to encourage Chad to keep studying. And
if you have more questions, feel free to
send them right in. Well, we're going to
go to Pastor James Rafferty with the
next question. We want to thank Nelly
from Virginia who sent it in. It says
like this. I am using the New King James
Bible to study with. We were studying
Daniel 3. When the pastor pointed out
that the word sackbutt was left out of
the New King James Version, he felt the
word sac was a misinterpretation in the
King James version. So they left it out
of the King James version. Is this
correct? What Bible version is the most
accurate to the original manuscripts?
Nelly wants to know. Pastor Rafferty,
>> thank you, Nelly, for your question.
It's a couple questions there and
they're really good. I just want to say
that uh it depends on what manuscript
you're talking about. But when we get to
the King James, uh we're going to find
uh in the New King James and the NIV and
the ESV and the NASB and all the
different versions of the Bible, we're
going to find that no Bible is
absolutely perfect. You're just not
going to find perfection in any of these
translations. So with that said, I
encourage people get as many
translations of the Bible as you can get
and compare them so that you can get a
fuller understanding of the text.
However, I would uh point out that there
are two historical roots or trees from
which we get our our Bible versions
today. Let me just try to rephrase that.
Each Bible version that we have today
goes back to an original source either
the text receptist or the Alexandrian
text. The King James and the New King
James go to the Texas receptus and the
other translations of the Bible which
are based on the Westcot Hort or Nestles
uh Greek go back to the Alexandrian
text. Now those Alexandrian text are
thought to be older and therefore more
reliable than the Textus Receptus.
However, this is not necessarily the
case in my opinion. In my opinion, older
doesn't necessarily mean better. It's
like a pair of shoes that don't fit
right. If they're uncomfortable, you're
not going to wear them. And if you're
not going to wear them, they're going to
last a lot longer. Whereas, it's if you
have a comfortable pair of shoes, you're
going to wear them more and you're going
to wear them out sooner. The King James
version and the New King James Version
are based upon the Texas receptus which
was thought at the time, this is going
back many years to be a more reliable
manuscript and more accurate manuscript.
And so it was used more and therefore
worn out more. I'm giving you a little
bit of history here uh than the uh
Alexandrian text. Now, if you'd like a
summary of this history, you can get a
book from Amazing Facts. It's called The
Faithful Witness by Sharon Cruz. That's
the faithful witness by Sharon Cruz from
Amazing Facts. As a quick summary of
this history that we've just uh talked
about, but just getting into the text of
the Bible now, which Bible or which
version is more accurate? I would say
the KJV is a must to have in your
library. Now, you may not want to preach
with a KJV. You may not want to do Bible
studies with a KJV. may be difficult for
you to understand, but it's a must to
have in your library if you're going to
be a serious student of the Bible. Why
is that? Well, there's a couple of
reasons. The first reason is when you
come to words that have been added to
the text, that is the Greek or the
English translation, but are not
supported by the Hebrew, the Greek or
the Aramaic for parts of the book of
Daniel, you're going to find that those
words are italicized. I'll give you an
example. In Daniel chapter 8 and verse
12, it talks about the daily sacrifice
being taken away. Now that word
sacrifice is italis italicized. That
means it's been added to the text. The
word should actually just read the daily
was taken away. And this will mean a lot
when you're studying Bible prophecy. The
point is this. There are many words that
are added to some of the newer
translations that are not italicized and
you can conclude that they are part of
the original text when they're not. And
I'll give you an example of that. In the
Message Bible in Revelation 1:10, it
says, "I was in the spirit on Sunday."
Well, Sunday is not an accurate
translation of the Greek word for that
particular day, the Lord's day. And so,
what you have now is a mistransation of
the text. and you wouldn't even know it.
A lot of people would think, "Oh, that's
talking about the Lord's day." That is
Sunday. According to the Message Bible,
another problem you're going to find is
that there are words that are added to
verses. Uh in in the Gospels, there are
a number of texts that have been uh I
would say added to to make it sound like
Jesus Christ did away with the unclean
food laws that were prescribed in the
book of Leviticus. The words have been
added to say by saying this Jesus
pronounced all foods clean. That is not
in the original text. You won't find
that phrase in the King James. You won't
even find it in the New King James, but
you will find it in some of the
translations that are based on the Al
Alexandrian text like the NIV, etc. So,
it is important to have a King James or
a New King James in your library. But if
we're going to pick between those two,
I'm going to go with the King James. Why
is that? Because when you get to
important doctrines, not like sacbot,
which is a lear, which you know may or
may not have been in the verse. There
may be six instruments in the verse in
Daniel 3. There may be seven instruments
in the verse in Daniel 3. Not a big
deal. That's not going to uh make or
break our salvation. But when you get to
Hebrews chapter 9, we're talking here
about the ascension of Christ into the
heavenly sanctuary. And in verse 12,
we're told that when Christ ascended, he
went into the holy place. King James
says in the New King James, it actually
says most holy place. That is a
mistransation of the Greek hagion. Hagon
infers holy. Hagon. Hagon. According to
Hebrews chapter 9 and verse three infers
most holy place. So holy place is the
best translation for verse 12. This is
important. Unlike the sacbot or the lear
being added or not being added in Daniel
chapter 3 in in Hebrews chapter 9 and
verse 12 we have an important critical
doctrinal teaching and that is when
Christ ascended to heaven did he go into
the holy place to the most holy place
and if he went into the holy place then
we have a foundation laid for his
transition to the most holy place in
1844. So, be sure and get that uh little
study by Sharon Cruz from Amazing Facts.
Our faith, the faithful witness. And if
you have any more questions about this,
be sure and let us know.
>> Amen. Thank you so much. The faithful
witness is the name of that book. All
right. Well, Shelley, are you ready for
your next question?
>> I'm ready. Well, Mike from Michigan sent
this email. And it says, "In the book of
Acts, God told Peter not to call
anything unclean that he had created.
And Jesus said that what goes into a
person does not defile them, but what
comes out does." In light of this, why
do some Christians still refrain from
eating pork? Mike wants to know.
>> Okay, Mike, this is a great question. It
was a question that I misunderstood for
many years. I mean, let's just walk
through this.
>> In Acts chapter 10, Peter sees a vision
of common and unclean animals. And then
the Lord tells him, "Rise up and eat."
And what does Peter do? He says, "Oh no,
Lord. I have never eaten anything common
and unclean." Now this is years after
Christ resurrected. So Peter is still
observing dietary laws. But then in Acts
10:15,
the Lord says, "What God has cleansed,
you must not call it." So many assume
that this is God declaring all animals
clean for food. But if you keep reading
that is not what the Lord explained to
Peter. Peter himself
explains the meaning of the vision. Acts
10 and verse 28.
He is telling the other Jews about this
vision. And what was the conclusion? God
has shown me that I should not call any
man,
any human being common or unclean. So
the vision was not about diet. It was
about people the it was symbolic. God
was preparing Peter to go to the
Gentiles, specifically to Cornelius's
house. And he was trying to get Peter to
understand the gospel is for all
nations.
>> The issue was prejudice, not pork. So
Mark 7:15,
let's look at that that you mentioned.
Mark 17, this is regarding Jesus
statement that it's not what goes into a
man that defiles him, but what comes out
in context. What is Christ addressing?
Always study in context. He is
addressing ritual handwashing
traditions. He's not redefining clean
and unclean distinctions of the foods
found in Leviticus 11. the date was or
the debate was about ceremonial
definement, not dietary laws. You know,
it really helped me when I realized
all the way back to the Noah's arc, we
find in Genesis chapter 7 and chapter 8,
God
made a distinction between clean animals
and unclean animals. This is well before
Mount Si, well before the old covenant.
And
those those unclean animals were not to
be eaten. They were not to be
sacrificed. Only clean animals could be
eaten or sacrificed. And then we find in
Leviticus 11 and Deuteronom Deuteronomy
that pork is specifically listed as
unclean. I'll tell you why. The unclean
are scavengers. your shrimp, your
seafood, the shellfish, pork will eat
their own, a pig will eat its own baby.
They will eat anything that they will
eat human remains. They will eat a dead
dog. You look at the birds that are the
scavengers. God said, "Don't eat these.
These are my garbage collectors that I
create one." He didn't create them by
accident, but they'll just clean up the
things. So, here's what's Let's Let's go
back to Peter's vision. What's worth
noting is that even after Peter's
vision, years later, we find in Acts 15,
the Jerusalem Council is addressing food
issues
when discussing the gentile converts.
If pork had suddenly been declared
clean,
we would expect a much clearer apostolic
statement. But we don't see that in the
Bible that you never see where it says
that God has changed his dietary laws.
So Acts 10 actually what it was all
about. Mike,
God is removing the barriers between the
Jews and the Gentiles. He's not
abolishing dietary distinctions.
Ultimately, the message of Acts 10 is
much deeper. God is saying, "I want
everyone to enter into a covenant
relationship with me. Every nation,
tribe, and tongue." So, Peter's vision
wasn't about changing the menu for
Peter. It was about changing his mindset
because he was very prejudiced. Jews
were very prejudiced against Gentiles.
>> But once that message got across that
God was a covenant making, covenant
keeping God who wanted all men to be
saved. It changed the course of the
gospel forever.
>> Amen. Amen. Thank you, Shelly. I I
really admire how the Lord uses you to
explain the word. So you glory to God.
All right, guys. We are ready for James
Rafferty. Pastor Rafferty, we received
an email and you get to answer this
question. It says, "I told a friend that
the papacy is the antichrist and she
asked about the Bible's statement that
the antichrist will sit in the temple of
God." How does the how does that relate
to the idea of a future third temple?
And will such a temple actually be
rebuilt?
>> Great question. Thank you so much for
that question. You know, it's really
interesting how uh as Shelley just
explained how we get away from biblical
teaching. And when we look at the
prophecy in 2 Thessalonians chapter 2,
sitting in the temple of God, showing
himself that he is God, we suggest that
that temple is a literal building. But
when you get to the New Testament,
you're going to find that the temple,
the literal temple of Jerusalem was
actually left desolate by Christ. That
we transition to the heavenly sanctuary,
which we talked about uh just recently
in uh Hebrews chapter 9 verse 12. Christ
went to the holy place at his ascension
and now is in the most holy place. That
the literal temple in Jerusalem is no
longer God's temple. and rebuilding a
third temple there or fourth depending
on how many you want to count is not in
the Bible. The Bible tells us in 1
Corinthians chapter 3 16 and 17 that
what know you not that you are the
temple of God and the Holy Spirit dwells
in you? And we see the same thing
repeated in 1 Corinthians 6 19 and 20.
In Ephesians, it also talks about us
being spiritual ch stones of this temple
that Christ is building and Jesus Christ
is the chief cornerstone. So what does
it mean that antichrist is going to sit
in the temple of God if we are the
temple of God? Well, we need to
understand biblically what antichrist
is. The word antichrist is not found in
the book of revelation. It's not found
in 2 Thessalonians. It's actually found
in 1 John and it's found in 1 John
chapter 2 and then again in 1 John
chapter 4. And we need to recognize that
John has a specific point that he's
making when he describes Antichrist. In
1 John chapter 2, for example, he
describes the antichrist in the context
of verses 15-1 17. Here's what he says.
1 John chapter 2:15, "Love not the
world, neither the things that are in
the world. If any man loves the world,
the love of the father is not in him.
For all that is in the world, how much
is in the world? All that is in the
world, the lust of the flesh, the lust
of the eyes, and the pride of life is
not of the father, but is of the world.
And the world passes away. 17. And the
lust thereof, but whoever does the will
of God abides forever. Now verse 18. And
little children, it is the last time.
And as you have heard that antichrist
shall come even now we know even now
there are many antichrists whereby we
know that it is the last time. I want to
make a suggestion here that may seem a
little radical to some people and that
is the idea that antichrist is the
system of this world that is seeking to
put itself in the place of Christ in our
hearts. Let me just say that again.
Antichrist is the system of this world.
Anything in this world that is seeking
to put itself in the place of Christ in
our hearts in this body temple. Now let
me give you an example of that. When
Jesus Christ was tempted by the devil in
the wilderness in Matthew chapter 4, the
devil came to him at one point and he
offered him everything in this world. If
he would worship him, if Christ would
worship the devil, he could have the
whole world would be his. And Jesus
Christ of course said no. Human beings
say yes. And the devil doesn't even give
us the whole world. He just gives us a
little bit of it. How many of us allow
this world to replace the word of God in
this body temple? Let me give you
another example.
In Ezekiel chapter 8, we are told that
God's people, Israel, were in the temple
of God with their backs toward the
sanctuary and they were worshiping the
sun toward the east. And that is
allowing antichrist to be put in this
temple in the place of God. You see the
word antichrist doesn't mean just mean
against. It also means in the place of
anything we put in the place of God in
this body temple in our theology in our
thinking in our worship in in our eating
in our drink everything that we put in
the put in the place of Christ which is
the word the place of the word of God
because Christ is the word John chapter
one is antichrist. We're putting
something in the place of Christ. And
that is why when we come to the very
last crisis in revelation chapter 13
where no man can buy or sell that the
antichrist power the devil himself is
leveraging the world against us
leveraging the world against people
because the world has people have put so
much of the world into their lives.
They've yielded so much step by step to
worldly demands and worldly principles
that they're not going to find it a hard
matter to yield to the principle of
Antichrist in these last days. So there
doesn't need to be a third temple. We
are the temple of God and Antichrist
wants to place himself in this body
temple by his traditions, by his
teachings, by anything worldly that
replaces the word of God. Be it our
doctrines, our practice, be it anything
that we do in our lifestyle. Anything
that is not founded in the word of God
is against God. As we read in 1 Timothy
chapter 2 15-1 17, all that is in the
world, right, is not of God, but is of
the world and is against the will of
God. And this is the system, the spirit
of Antichrist.
>> Amen. Thank you so much, Pastor
Rapherty. And thank you um at home for
sending that email. um to us. All right,
so we move on to the next question. This
is from Harvey from Canada who sent in
the email. And Shellyley, I recently
heard that some say Michael the
Archangel and Jesus are the same person.
If they are the same, how can it be the
Father, Son, and Holy Spirit Trinity?
Can you help me understand this, please?
Harvey, this is a question that we get
more questions about Michael the
Archangel. It's so I'm going to I've
answered this several times. I'm going
to take just a little bit different
approach today.
>> Okay.
>> First of all, let me just say Christ is
fully God. He's eternally one with the
Father and the Holy Spirit. And
scripture uses many names or titles if
you will to describe the Messiah,
Christ. Messiah actually is uh this is a
term and Christ they both mean the same.
Messiah is Hebrew, Christ is Greek means
the anointed one. And they both refer to
one of the persons of the Godhead. And
here's how we have to think about
what these what titles do is describe
they carry a theological meaning. In
other words, Messiah Greek Christ was
the anointed one.
Jesus is called the lamb of God who
takes away the sins of the world. The
lamb who was slain from the foundation
of the world. That name word lamb
doesn't mean that he was actually a
sheep. It just describes his role. So,
Michael the Archangel
is a title. There's many titles used
that describe Christ's authority and and
his leadership. Michael the Archangel
describes as the commander, the heavenly
commander. This does not deny his full
divinity. So let's look at this. Michael
means who is like God? It's a rhetorical
question and it begs the response, no
one. No one is like God. So the name
itself, Michael, is a declaration of
God's uniqueness and his supremacy.
That's why in passages like Daniel 12:1
and Revelation 12:7,
Michael appears in the context of
spiritual conflict. The very name
proclaims God's unmatched authority. So
now let's describe the word angel both
in the Hebrew and in the Greek. It's
Malik in the Hebrew. It's angalos in the
Greek. That word means messenger. And
the same word is used to describe the
created beings cherubam and saraphim.
But it's also and it will be like angel
then. But then it will be used to
describe
uh prophets. Same word prophets, men or
Christ himself. the the Messiah who is
the messenger of the covenant in Joshua
chapter five and verse 14.
The commander of the army of the Lord
was the Lord and he calls himself the
commander of the army of the Lord. So
we're not saying that Jesus is a created
being like that created beings the
cherubam and saraphim. They are God's
messengers. That's why they're called
angels. What we are saying is he's the
messenger of the covenant created. He he
was uh the ark of archangel means that
he's the head of it all. He's the Lord
of hosts, the chief of the angels, the
commander of the angels. But the Bible
is clear that Christ is eternal God.
Once again, John 1:1, in the beginning
was the word, the word was with God. The
word was God. And it goes on to say that
all things were created by him. John
8:58 Jesus said, "Before Abraham was, I
am." Colossians 2:9 he says in Paul says
in him dwells all the fullness of the
Godhead those three persons in one first
Thessalonians 4:16 the Lord descends
from heaven with the voice of the
archangel he is the commanding voice
over the angels not that he's one of
them by nature but that he is their
leader Amen. Thank you, Shelly. Thank
you. And lastly, Shellyley Michael sent
an email and it says, "How do we
reconcile dietary loss and
Sabbathkeeping with Paul's writings in 1
Timothy 4-5, Galatians 4:10, and
Colossians 2:16?"
>> Well, Michael, let's just address those
three passages of scripture. 1 Timothy 4
1-5,
Paul is warning about those who forbid
marriage and command abstinence from
certain foods which God created, he
says, to be received with thanksgiving.
Notice the key phrase there, which God
created to be received.
In Genesis chapter 7 and 8, we see the
first, you know, we have to understand
the first 11 chapters of Genesis cover
2,000 years of world history. Just
jammed into 11 chapters. Isn't that
amazing? I mean, there's only 4,100
years of of world history in the Bible.
But and and 4,000 of that is in the Old
Testament. Do not do not ignore the Old
Testament. We see God's way of dealing
with mankind for 4,000 years. But right
in the beginning at the ark, God made
the distinction between clean and
unclean foods, animals, and that unclean
were not to be eaten and they were not
to be sacrificed. So Paul's not
redefining that distinction. What he was
doing is confronting the aesthetic
teachers, those who taught severe
self-disipline and they were adding
manmade
restrictions beyond scripture. Verse
five of first Timothy 4 says that food
is sanctified by the word of God and
prayer. Well, the word of God has
already defined what food God's s
sanctified and it's very clear when you
read Genesis 7:8 and Leviticus 11. So,
let's look at Galatians 4:10. Paul says,
"You observe days and months and seasons
and years."
Paul is addressing the Galatian, the
gentile believers who were being
pressured to adopt the ceremonial
system of the Mosaic law as a means of
salvation. That's what these Hebrew the
Jewish people who they converted to
Christianity but they didn't understand
or they were going around and making
trouble.
So the issue here is not a weekly
Sabbath or the Ten Commandments but
reliance on ritual obs observances for
justification. Paul's entire argument in
Galatians is about salvation by grace.
So now let's look at Colossians 2:16.
Let no one judge you in food or in drink
or in regarding a festival or a new moon
or Sabbath plural with a small s. That
phrase follows the Old Testament
ceremonial calendar pattern, the annual
festivals, the monthly new moons, and
the ceremonial Sabbaths that were
connected to feast days. And they could
land on any day of the week. But verse
17 calls them a shadow of things to
come. This was all symbolic. They were
shadows pointing forward to Christ. So
the weekly Sabbath was established at
creation and it's not a shadow. It was
not a shadow of the cross there. It
preceded sin. It preeded redemption. So
Paul is opposing legalism and ceremonial
shadow obser observances that were being
imposed by these people who were coming
out of Judaism. They were still hanging
on to that and they were telling these
new converts, you got to do this to be
saved. You've got to you've got to be
circumcised to be saved. And Paul's
opposing all of that. The New Testament
consistently teaches freedom from
ceremonial shadows, not freedom from
loving obedience to our creator.
>> Thank you very much, Shelley, and thank
you, Michael, for sending in your email
with that question. We're going to take
a break right now, and please stand by.
We'll be right back.
>> If you're enjoying our 3ian Bible Q&A,
then tell your friends. Each Monday,
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's holy word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand. To have your questions
answered on a future program, just email
them to us at bibleqa3abn.tv.
That's bible qa3abn.tv.
You may also text your questions to
6182283975.
That's 618-228-3975.
Be sure to include your name and where
you live and then watch through Bible
Q&A for answers from God's word.
>> Well, friends, we just have a few words
to um close this up and we want to thank
you for participating. Pastor Raferty,
you have any words for our viewers?
>> Yeah, I just wanted to touch on Mark
chapter 7. It ties in with what I was
saying about the different Bible
versions on the question I got and also
in what Shelley was saying in verse 19
of Mark chapter 7. It says because it
enterth into the heart but not into the
belly and goes out in the drop purging
all meats. The NASV, the NIV, the ASV,
the ESV, the RSV all say in saying this,
Jesus declared all foods clean. That is
not in the Greek text. Those words have
been added. So, it's very important for
us to have a version of the Bible that
is accurate to the Greek and accurate to
the Hebrew. And the King James is that,
but of course, we want to maybe be able
to compare other versions of the Bible
also.
>> Thank you for your comment, Shellyley.
Thank you so much.
>> Oh, thank you for being with us today
and we love you.
>> It's a pleasure. And folks, don't forget
this is your program. We want to hear
from you and you know the Lord draw nice
to us and as we seek him, he will speak
to us. I pray that your ears will be
sensitive to his voice and that you will
heed to his counsel. May the Lord bless
you and we will see you in the other
episodes of your program 3A and today
Bible Q&A.
Heat.